en segundos
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión
de los observadores de france 24 cierre
blanco como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos esta semana comenzamos en
yemen donde les vamos a mostrar la
difícil situación de los refugiados
etíopes perseguidos por los rebeldes
hutíes hasta el punto de que algunos han
decidido devolverse a su país por otro
lado vamos hasta brasil donde nuestro
observador miembro de la comunidad
mapuche nos muestra las entrañas y lo
peligroso y lo difícil que es la
extracción de oro ilegal para las
comunidades indígenas
estos refugiados etíopes protestan
porque son perseguidos por los rebeldes
hutíes que controlan en el noroeste de
yemen y que intenta reclutar los para
que luchen con ellos o encerrarlos para
obtener dinero cada vez son más los
refugiados de la etnia oromo que
finalmente deciden volver a casa a un
país del que habían huido incluso si eso
significa arriesgar sus vidas
el 12 de abril 50 de ellos murieron
cuando su embarcación se hundió frente a
la costa de yibutí
nuestra observadora intenta sensibilizar
sobre la situación de los refugiados que
se ha agravado en las últimas semanas
y de hecho vienen a yemen para luego ir
a arabia saudita cuando llegan de
etiopía primero desembarcan en adén
desde allí toman taxis y van a saná
pero en cuanto los combatientes sutiles
ven que son negros lo sacan de los taxis
los acorralan y los llevan al centro de
detención de saná una vez en el centro
de detención son maltratados les pegan a
veces no tienen comida así que iniciaron
una huelga de hambre el 4 de marzo su
principal petición era ser repatriados a
su país
en este centro controlado por los
rebeldes hutíes la huelga de los
migrantes de un giro dramático el 7 de
marzo
los enfrentamientos con los guardias el
centro fue incendiado según las
autoridades útiles 44 personas murieron
en esta tragedia una cifra ampliamente
subestimada según las asociaciones que
defienden los derechos de los aromos
quienes hablan de cientos de víctimas
tras el incendio muchos refugiados se
reunieron frente a la sede del alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas para
los refugiados exigiendo que los
responsables fueran llevados ante la
justicia
y que los muertos fueran enterrados
[Música]
y el 2 de abril el plantón fue
dispersado por la fuerza todos los
refugiados inmigrantes etíopes que están
en yemen quieren volver a su país sus
vidas están en peligro a menudo ni
siquiera se atreven a salir de sus casas
son víctimas de acoso quiero que la
opinión pública conozca la causa de los
refugiados que se encuentran actualmente
en saná según la organización
internacional para las migraciones más
de 11.000 migrantes han regresado a sus
países de origen desde mayo de 2020
aries gando sus vidas en embarcaciones
clandestinas
desde hace varios meses los indígenas
brasileños denuncian la ocupación de las
tierras de la raposa serra do sol en el
norte de brasil por parte de los
buscadores de oro la presencia de estos
buscadores de oro ilegales fue
documentada en marzo con imágenes aéreas
con normativa actual pero ayude estas
prácticas pero el presidente brasileño
jair bolsonaro fomenta la exploración
minera en tierras indígenas como lo
explica nuestro observador representante
del pueblo más cuchi esta ola de mineros
ilegales en tierras indígenas ha
aumentado en parte por el discurso del
presidente de la república y también
porque a principios de año el propio
gobierno del estado de roraima elaboró
un proyecto de ley para legalizar la
extracción de oro
y
esto animó a quienes ya estaban en la
zona y a los que querían venir
estos buscadores de oro no sólo vienen
de roraima sino de otros estados y
también de guyana y de venezuela
está aquí denuncia
estamos renunciando a estas actividades
intentando concienciar a las autoridades
de este problema de la mejor manera
posible para que tomen medidas
[Música]
esto pone en riesgo nuestras vidas
y buscadores de oro nos amenazan por que
alertamos sobre estas actividades
ilegales las comunidades indígenas están
preocupadas por la destrucción de sus
tierras y la contaminación de los suelos
y las fuentes de agua con productos
químicos tóxicos pero esa fiebre del oro
también es motivo de división
también hay un impacto social la misma
familia dentro de las comunidades están
dejando sus labores cotidianas sus
comunidades su trabajo su ganadería para
trabajar en la minería pensando que será
una solución a los problemas económicos
en nuestra organización realmente
intentamos trabajar en proyectos de
agricultura sostenible trabajamos con
los jóvenes sobre semillas tradicionales
sobre artesanías para la plantación de
varios tipos de cultivos
estamos tratando de reforzar esta línea
de trabajo para mostrarles a las
comunidades que existen otros recursos a
partir del potencial de cada región
[Música]
en marzo en el estado de roraima se
dictó una decisión judicial que evoca el
riesgo de genocidio y que exige la
expulsión de los buscadores de oro
presentes en las tierras de los yanomami
otro pueblo víctima de la minería en
brásil
y esta manera llegamos al final de
nuestro programa por esta semana
recuerden que todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla y esperamos sus
fotos y videos aficionados hasta una
próxima oportunidad
[Música]